الغاز التالي معروف لمئات
الآلاف من المتابعين حول العالم
حيث أن المسافر المتنقل Nomad Mahine هو
مسافر مغامر كان في الخرطوم
عندما اندلع العنف
وانتشرت مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة به فيروسية ، هذه الصورة مأخوذة
من طائرة بدون طيار تظهر طائرة تحترق في
المطار الدولي
وهذا الفيديو ، يمكنك مشاهدة الأشخاص الذين
يفرون من العاصمة بالسيارة أو
سيرًا على الأقدام ، وقد يفسر هذا جزئيًا سبب
وجود الرفوف الفارغة في محلات السوبر ماركت ، ومن
الواضح أن الناس يتوقفون عن تخزين ما يمكنهم تخزينه
أو ماهين حيث ينضم إلي الآن عبر Skype من
سطح في رسوم متحركة  من الجيد أن تكون
معنا ، أفهم أنك سمعت للتو
بعض الانفجارات خلفك ما
تراه بالضبط وأين أنت بالضبط في المدينة ،
لذا فأنا الآن بالقرب من
منطقة الصراع أه على بعد كيلومتر واحد فقط حول
منطقة الصراع و  الدخان
قادم فعليًا من على الأرجح أنه قادم
من المطار وهذا
شيء على بعد كيلومترين ونصف من
هنا ، لذلك في الصباح كان هناك انفجار هائل كبير في الصباح وبعد
ساعة واحدة لم يكن هناك انفجار أو
شيء ما ولكن أه طلقات نارية كانت  كان هناك
صوت أه قصف صغير كان
يحدث مرة أخرى كما كان قبل 20 دقيقة فقط كان هناك
قصف هائل والآن
أعيرة نارية واه صوت دبابة
يمكننا أن نسمع من هنا وأنا أفهم أنك
كنت تسافر ببساطة عبر السودان عندما كان
هذا الصراع  اندلعت خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع عندما كنت
في شرفة بدأت
التصوير ، فهل لديك أي فكرة عما كان
يحدث في ذلك الوقت ، خذنا إلى
ما شاهدته ،
لذلك لم يكن لدي أي فكرة أنني هنا في
السودان منذ الشهر الماضي  لذلك
وصلت للتو في رسم كاريكاتوري للعاصمة قبل
يومين فقط من بدء النزاع ، لذا
لم أكن في البداية ليس لدي أي
فكرة أه ولكن فيما بعد عرفت أنه
صراع بين عراسي وجد
الجيش السوداني الرسمي
وأنت  من الواضح أنك كنت تستخدم
هذه اللقطات المأخوذة من الطائرة بدون طيار
فوق العاصمة ، خذنا من خلال ما
التقطته ، ومدى الدمار الذي شاهدته
وعدد الأشخاص الذين تشاهدهم
يفرون من
العنف ،
آسف تعال مرة أخرى ، هل يمكنك أن تأتي مرة أخرى
لك  لقد أخذنا بعض الرؤية المذهلة للطائرة بدون طيار
فوق العاصمة ، هل يمكنك وصف
نوع الدمار الذي
تراه وما الذي يتم استهدافه آه
اليوم أيضًا في الواقع ، لقد أخذنا
طائرتنا بدون طيار لتطير إلى هناك
وكان صديقي هناك وفجأة فقدنا
السيطرة ونرى طلقة أه ضخمة
في الطائرة التي كانت
تحترق بالفعل هناك
أجنبية